jeremy so my question would be people
can earn uh on usdc somewhere between
six to seven percent yield kind of
depending on the length of the term how
are you able to do that versus
traditional lending instruments it's a
great question um and there's actually a
a good amount of info out there on this
on on our website and others so the the
way to think about this today
is
the the yields on usdc today are are
driven by demand in the crypto capital
markets uh and when i say crypto capital
markets i mean all of the different
investing trading lending other capital
market activity that's happening in
digital asset native infrastructure
whether that's on centralized exchanges
or or on defy and within that arena
there is a very significant amount of
dollar stable point borrowing demand
there are in in principally from our
perspective
very high quality institutional
borrowers and these range from
asset managers and other forms of asset
allocators to
hedge funds to
otc firms electronic markets firms you
know many many other institutional
market participants who want to borrow
dollar stable coins uh and put those to
work in these markets and they're
willing to pay
uh high interest rates for that and if
and they're willing to pay those high
interest rates because they're actually
generating significantly higher returns
and they can't go to jpmorgan chase or
they can't go to goldman sachs to borrow
stable coins and so there is this
intrinsic market demand that exists and
this has existed for years and years and
years
i operated one of the largest occ
trading desks for a long time
and we borrowed
all the time and it was a really
powerful way to augment the working
capital that you had as a firm and so
that that's just going on it's going on
a much much larger level now there's
also a retail dimension to that which is
a lot of the borrowing against uh
protocols like ave and compound and
others
that's very much individuals
we exclusively lend on a wholesale basis
to institutional borrowers uh and i
think what also makes the the approach
that we're taking unique is a it's you
know certainly it's these high interest
rates that are that are you know
you know being paid but secondly we
actually over collateralize
every single every single loan so if
you're lending a million usdc through us
we're actually um
we're getting
1.25 million dollars in bitcoin
collateral against that and we're
constantly adjusting the amount of btc
based on intraday price movements to
ensure that we're always in that 125
percent collateralization so not only is
it a uh uh you know a high yield it's
also a secured uh over collateralized uh
you know um you know you know asset as
well so i think that also makes it
pretty interesting